when we joined back in what 2018 the
channel was just getting off the ground
and we were tasked with building it into
something great it was already a solid
foundation some good content was coming
out but there was an opportunity to do a
lot more and build it into a stronger
resource for developers I was so excited
to join this new team of cloud content
creators but looking back I had no idea
all the cool things that I was going to
get to work on or just how big this
whole thing was going to get I feel like
I know everything about Film Production
now Hollywood get ready from all of us
here at Google Cloud thank you so much
for letting us be part of your developer
journey and from everyone on our team
here we can't wait to see what you build
next